peripheral neuropathy is a common
condition occurring when injury or
disease damages your peripheral nervous
system originating from your brain and
spinal cord peripheral nerves extend to
your skin muscle and tissues
your peripheral nervous system relays
vital information between your body and
the brain in the form of electrical
impulses
there are three types of peripheral
nerves motor nerves regulate the
movements of your body's skeletal
muscles sensory nerves transmit
sensations such as heat vibration touch
and pain to the brain
autonomic nerves regulate the activities
of internal organs and glands each nerve
is made up of many interconnected cells
called neurons that transmit impulses at
lightning speed this constant exchange
allows your brain to respond to vital
input from your body
however damage to the nerves disrupts
this critical link resulting in
peripheral neuropathy
damage to a single nerve called mono
neuropathy usually results from injury
or repetitive stress an example of mono
neuropathy is carpal tunnel syndrome
repeated impact to the nerve in your
wrist may cause tingling pain and
weakness in your hand arm and shoulder
meant of multiple nerves called
polyneuropathy is far more common
damage typically begins in the nerves
farthest from the central nervous system
and progresses symmetrically
polyneuropathy can be caused by diabetes
and other systemic diseases infections
or exposure to toxic substances
one or all of the three nerve types may
be affected and symptoms are specific to
each damage to sensory nerves
characteristic of diabetes can lead to
numbness in your hands and feet with
diminished ability to detect temperature
insensitivity to pain or over
sensitivity to pain
polyneuropathy may also cause damage to
your motor nerves which can result in
muscle weakness twitching and pain
common signs of autonomic nerve damage
include intolerance to heat loss of
bladder control gastrointestinal
disturbances impairment of breathing
and impairment of heart rate
generally treatment of peripheral
neuropathy is aimed at treating the
underlying cause and providing
symptomatic relief
if you have mono neuropathy you may
receive pain relief medications physical
therapy to maintain muscle strength or
surgery to release compressed or
entrapped nerves if you have
polyneuropathy your doctor will treat
the underlying disease to prevent
further damage to the nerves
he or she may recommend pain medication
to relieve your symptoms if you have
polyneuropathy with sensory impairment
your doctor may recommend orthopedic
shoes to prevent foot injury